on est vraiment dans les travaux
d'impression des bulletins de vote plus
que quelques jours avant le vote par
anticipation des centaines de milliers
d'électeurs exerceront leurs droits de
vote les 25 et 26 septembre élections
Québec veut accommoder comme lors de
chaque élection le plus grand nombre de
Québécois en 2018 près 2 millions
d'électeurs avaient voté avant le jour
du scrutin on se déplace aussi au
domicile des électeurs incapables de se
déplacer pour des raisons de santé en
revanche lors de la dernière élection 2
millions de Québécois inscrits sur la
liste électorale non pas voté certains
par des intérêts d'autres en raison d'un
contretemps
à l'aéroport de Montréal de nombreux
voyageurs se préparent à quitter le pays
on tente trop tôt pour le vote par
anticipation on en revient trop tard
pour les élections plusieurs d'entre eux
comme ce fils et sa mère aurait souhaité
voter par la poste depuis l'étranger
mais ils ont dû abandonner l'idée en
raison de la complexité des procédures
je pensais que ça allait être plus
simple genre une lettre par la poste ou
quelque chose comme ça mais non c'est
c'est vraiment compliqué un peu déçu
parce que ça va être la première fois
dans ma vie que je manque comme on vote
seulement 3500 électeurs se sont
inscrits au vote hors Québec cette année
parmi eux ce camionneur longue distance
qui travaille surtout aux États-Unis
j'ai toujours voté à toutes les
élections alors là je m'attendais à ce
que ce soit facile comme on fédéral la
dernière fois j'étais avant couvert
alors j'ai pu voter par la poste
Frédéric Bisson raconte avoir fait des
pieds et des mains pour recevoir sa
trousse de vote par la poste la plupart
de mes collègues ont juste dit moi je
voterai pas la semaine trop compliqué ça
a pas de bon sens
rien pour faciliter l'accès au vote
l'élection tombe en pleine saison de
chasse les chasseurs sont nombreux à
nous poser des questions à savoir
comment faire pour pour voter alors
qu'on est absent pendant les jours de
vote
pour un mois et là il y a un choix à
faire dans la vie est-ce qu'il veut
voter
il veut aller chasser élection Québec
veut rendre le vote accessible à tous
c'est pourquoi en plus du vote par
antipathion 5 journées de vote
supplémentaires sont prévus entre le 23
et le 29 septembre au bureau du
directeur du scrutin ici alsacienne
Radio-Canada Montréal